Film Courage: Harvey, once you say “Yes”
to a project, what are some of the first steps?
Harvey Mason, Jr.: When I take on a project,
I start researching it, looking back at what
they’ve done before or reading any kind
of background material, scripts, outlines,
things like that.
If it’s an artist, I’m listening to all
of the music that they have recorded, what
the voices are, listening to who maybe the
actors are.
And in the case of some of these movies, you’re
looking back at the history of the music that
is going to be featured in the film and kind
of seeing…Okay, what can I do to these songs
to make them contemporary and relevant.
How can I push them?
How careful do I have to be because there
is some classic copyrights there that you
don’t want to tamper with?
So you start researching it and then you start
laying out an organizational plan on how you
are going to attack the project.
The latest film I am working on had about
70 songs in it.
So you have to be a little bit strategic with
how you do it.
My next project is kind of broken out into
three different groups of styles of songs
so I kind of start organizing it.
The next step is to start casting and thinking
about who am I going to use…the director’s
casting the film.
I am casting the music.
Who am I going to use to create the right
sound for each individual piece of music?
And luckily living in Los Angeles, we have
access to the best musicians and best vocalists,
so I can pull from an amazing group of talent.
But part of my job is to specifically make
sure that the people that I bring in accomplish
the sound that I want for that particular
piece of music.
Film Courage: Okay…let’s talk about SING
(movie) then.
So once they presented you with the script
and you knew who some of the voice actors
were, how did you fit the different songs
for each character?
Harvey Mason, Jr.: Well that was a trick because
there was so much material and so many characters
but ultimately what the job was for me was
to take kind of the playlist that they had
put together and figure out what was the personality
of each character and how can I translate
that into kind of a sonic, genre specific
sound for them.
So Ash (Scarlett Johansson’s character)
the porcupine is real edgy, rocky.
So we just knew the songs that she was going
to do just had to have that edge.
Reese’s character is kind of pop, a cleaner-cut
pop artist.
So really it was about recognizing the personality
of the artist and then figuring out which
songs worked for them and then ultimately
making sure that I gave them that consistent
sound.
Film Courage: Now once you decided which artist
you were going to use, what is your process?
Are you contacting the song writer or the
artist themselves who performed it?
What is the process like in getting approval?
Harvey Mason, Jr.: Once the songs were chosen
and approved by the heads of the studio, there
is another person who works with us.
His name is Jojo Villanueva.
He’s the music supervisor.
So his job is specifically to go in and license
and clear all of these songs.
I think he cleared almost 100 pieces of music.
So that process involves going to the publisher,
going to the artists’ record companies,
the performers, all those people, depending
on if we’re going to use the actual master
recording or if we’re going to recreate
it, there are a bunch of different variables
there.
But he has to reach out and negotiated all
those fees and prices and usage and that’s
a nutty job.
He’s been doing that for SING movie for
almost two years.
That’s a big job!
Film Courage: Wow!
Were there some songs that you presented and
thought “You know this would be a great
match!”
I know you had Elton John, Stevie Wonder,
Leonard Cohen (songs) in the movie.
But what if other people didn’t think it
was a match?
And what is your process for proving your
point or working with them (possibly just
turning over the control to what they want).
What was this like?
Harvey Mason, Jr.: Well to be honest, I didn't
choose a lot of the songs.
I added my opinion and there are a few songs
that I brought to the table, but a lot of
the songs are chosen by the director.
And so because he chose those songs there
wasn’t a lot of people we had to prove it
to.
Maybe Chris Meledandri, the head of the studio,
but for the most part it was really knowing
the songs he wanted and then how do we make
those songs work in the context of the film
and that was the position I was in.
I mean Garth loves this song but he doesn’t
know how to piece it together, how it’s
going to fit.
He’s not even sure that it is.
If anything I am almost taking his idea and
trying to prove it back.
I’m like “Yeah, Garth.
That’s a great song title.
Let’s figure out how we can flip it.”
In other cases like the grand finale songs,
there was some uncertainty about those songs.
We went back and forth.
We tried three or four different songs in
different spots.
We would do little rough demos.
Don’t You Worry About a Thing was one in
particular where we did a lot of versions
of and improvements too.
We started in one place, we started here and
ended up way over here on that song.
Ultimately you’re just trying to create
the right emotional feel, to hit the right
beats for the director and the story with
the music so you’re choosing the songs based
on that.
But once they’re chosen you can take a song
ten different ways in production.
It’s all how you produce it: the tempo,
the key, the instrumentation.
So as long as I was aware of what the song
needed to accomplish, I was able to take those
songs and manipulate them to kind of fit the
scene.
Question for the Viewers: How is your process
of incorporating music into a movie the same
or different?